I was shocked by how many people at FBI were at
Twitter I mean we're not talking just low-level
people although they were they were there
too but we're talking the former general
counsel to FBI this is like one of the most senior
Executives we're talking the Deputy Chief of Staff
I discovered a set of other extremely troubling
uh behaviors including by former FBI Executives
including the former general counsel the FBI who
was then the second the deputy general counsel
within Twitter basically you know him arguing for
censoring the laptop within Twitter and this is
the same person who was involved in initiating
the whole Russia gate the FBI investigation of
trump in the first place when he was at Twitter
we know that there was that FBI and and the
intelligence agencies organized a little group
of all the social media companies and they would
have regular meetings particularly in the run-up
to elections the the journalists themselves are
behaving in really weird Behavior I mean when
you imagine journalists get together to talk
about how not to cover an issue or how to kind of
squelch an issue you know so that by the time the
Hunter buying laptop came out they had all been
mentally programmed to view it as this information
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constance and kissing and this is a
show for you if you want honest conversations with
Fascinating People our brilliant guest today is
the author of a number of books and the co-founder
of the Public Sub stack publication which I read
almost every day Michael schellenberger welcome
back to trigonometry good to be with you guys
again uh it's great to have you on listen uh
we obviously had the first conversation with
you and people can go back and watch that to talk
about San Francisco your book and and things like
that but tell us what you've been up to since we
last spoke because uh you've been doing quite a
lot of good journalistic work particularly
the Twitter files which we'll talk about uh
what have you been up to yeah I mean the big news
personally is that I was under contract to do two
additional books one on nuclear energy and then
a third for harpercollins that was sort of going
to be the last of a series on the ways in which
civilized civilizations undermine themselves from
within which is uh kind of where apocalypse never
in San Francisco ended up and I I just gave back
both book advances because I decided that I wanted
to be writing full-time on sub stack I just love
the I love being in the news I love publishing on
topics that are in the news I think it's a really
great way to you know for me it's good personally
I love the investigative work and I love we're
doing this kind of combination of investigative
and then we do explanatory journalism after that
and then we also have a fair amount of you know
trying to inspire people about some more positive
project and not just be totally negative so my
friend Layton Woodhouse joined and since January
1st it's been we are now just doing public uh at
sub stack full-time and then I'm also continuing
to do work through with my research organization
environmental progress really working on two big
campaigns the first is to have a much stronger
response to the addiction driven homelessness
crisis which is particularly acute in the west
of the United States but is also in other big
cities and then the other is to protect endangered
species that are being threatened by industrial
renewable energy projects particularly a large
industrial Wind Farm off the coast of the East
Coast which threatens the North Atlantic
right whale of which there's only 340 left
in the world and they can experience no more
population declines without risk of Extinction
the whooping cranes which are threatened by big
wind transmission projects in the in the Midwest
and the desert tortoises in California which are
threatened by a big industrial well not one but
many industrial solar projects so that's what
I'm up to and it's we're having a great time
and you know as you guys know we were involved
in the Twitter files I've also been a big critic
of the world economic Forum so I'm excited to
get into those topics with you guys well we're
going to talk to you about both the the cabal
of pedo lizards or whatever whatever it is at
Davos but first let's talk about the Twitter
files because um I I don't know what happened
exactly I I spent quite a bit of time going why
is no media covering this but it was literally
a complete blackout and if you just watched the
BBC CNN if you read the Times the telegraph the
the whatever you would not have had any idea
that any of this was happening so first of all
tell us what what the Twitter files reveal what
were they about and secondly what does this mean
sure so um everyone knows that Elon Musk the
founder of Tesla and SpaceX bought Twitter at a
much inflated price he told us that he probably
paid about three times more than it was worth
he's taken over the company it's been a chaotic
situation by his account um trying to figure out
the algorithms and he wanted to have a fresh
start so he invited in a number of journalists
to basically go through the emails and internal
records of Twitter Executives to understand how
Twitter was responding on some pretty big events
I was brought in by my friend Barry Weiss who runs
the sub stack publication the Free Press I was
a bit of an odd choice in the sense that I was
the only one of the journalists involved that have
ever explicitly criticized Elon Musk in print I've
done so actually for almost a decade including in
Mother Jones magazine but also I criticized his
statements around solar panels in Apocalypse
never so some of the people kind of jump to
some assumptions that he Cherry that he picked us
picked each of us that's not the case when I met
him he said he didn't know didn't know who I was
so if that's true then he wasn't cherry picking
the reporters and even if he did know who I was
and he was picking somebody who had been a Critic
of his we had pretty free access to the files
we would ask for searches related to particular
topics time periods and executives and the big
picture is just that many of the things that
people had suspected that there was a explicit
throttling or what they call de-amplification
in popular parlance is called Shadow Banning that
was definitely occurring with disfavored voices
certainly with with people right of Center it was
occurring but it was also occurring with critics
of the covid lockdowns with vaccine mandates you
know some of the most egregious was having I mean
here you have Twitter Executives responding under
pressure from the White House or from just other
Advocates including CDC and others to basically
censor or label tweets by people with reasonably
different points of view on covid mandates to
give you one example Martin Kulldorff at Harvard
University tweeted you know not everybody needs
to get a vaccine you know particularly young kids
like zero to five don't don't probably need
it maybe the most reasonable thing one could
say about the vaccine he was not suggesting that
vaccines are involved in some conspiracy I think
he even says that some people you know that people
should get them and it was labeled by by Twitter
by people at Twitter who frankly were not nearly
as qualified as Martin Kulldorff I was involved
in I did two uh Twitter threads the first on the
decision to de-platform president Trump and then
the second on the decision to censor the hunter
Biden laptop so those are the two topics I know
best these are topics I had not written on
before and so there was the on the one hand
um a kind of Crash Course on learning
both issues and then also I think bringing
what Buddhists call beginner's Minds to those
topics which was something that as I've gotten
older I've come to appreciate more because
there's a shock when you see what's going on
that I think people that are more jaded that a
minute no longer don't have and the first is I
think the key thing for people to understand about
both is that the internal Twitter staff analysis
both of the hunter Biden laptop and of the Trump
tweets that got him banned from the platform the
internal decision was that they had not violated
Twitter's own terms of service in other words the
the staff looked at it and went all the way up
to the head of of trust and safety and they said
these were tweets that were not in violation
of Twitter's rules so they changed the rules in
order to be able to achieve the objective first of
de-platforming trump and then of censoring Hunter
Biden's laptop now I am a bit more sympathetic
to the position that there's some amount of
content moderation that must occur inside
these platforms for reasons but good and bad
um but there is some content moderation I occur
so I'm not suggesting that there's no content
moderation and I'm also I also think the fact
of the matter is these guys were just making up
the rules as they went and there's no other way it
could be because there were no rules and and rules
were also being adjusted to real world events and
that's also understandable so not so the fact that
they changed rules is in itself not necessarily
problematic however in the case of the Trump
de-platforming my view and this is now I think
probably a majority or mainstream view at least
among certainly the um Jack Dorsey the former
CEO and founder of Twitter shares this view is
that they should not have de-platformed him
and that they really had many tools at their
disposal to be able to control what Trump was
saying including taking down uh tweets including
giving him a kind of time out what they call
bouncing somebody and that that decision was not
justified and had really serious ramifications
where you're taking obviously the head of the
Free World the someone who is democratically
elected and not allowing them to communicate
in ways that uh you know really they should
arguably be able to communicate at least if
they're not in Gross violation and it seems to
me that Twitter violated The public's trust in
that decision the other decision I think was even
more of a violation and that was the decision to
to uh censor effectively the hunter Biden laptop
Story by the New York Post on October 14th excuse
me um this was a decision of course that also CEO
Jack Dorsey said was the wrong decision it was
a decision that they reversed nonetheless what's
important about the episode is that the censorship
of the piece and then the and other things going
on including Former Intelligence uh Community
Representatives claiming that the laptop was
probably a result of Russian disinformation and
and Facebook censoring of the piece and widespread
enunciations of the laptop Story by others in the
news media all contributed to the perception that
the laptop's information was not legitimate uh you
know if you I mean I I reason I'm so confident of
that is because that's how I viewed it personally
and that's how other people viewed it at the
time including my family members they did not
think that this was they were all Democrats
who do not think that this is uh that the
laptop was legitimate or that it was pointing to
legitimate information and moreover I discovered
a set of other extremely troubling uh behaviors
including by former FBI Executives including the
former general counsel the FBI who was then the
second the deputy general counsel within Twitter
um basically you know him arguing for censoring
the laptop within Twitter and this is the same
person who was involved in initiating the whole
Russia gate the FBI investigation of trump in
the first place when he was at Twitter there's a
lot of FBI people in Twitter engaging activities
that we still don't totally understand we also
saw what was a kind of pre-bunking effort to
discredit the hunter Biden laptop before it became
publicly known by FBI agents going to Twitter
and Facebook and warning that there would be
potentially a hack and leak operation by Russians
um that would involve Hunter Biden and
it's important to understand that FBI had
the hunter Biden laptop um in December 2019
so almost a full year before the the laptop
was coming out you have FBI warning Twitter
and Facebook of some sort of a leak operation
I'm not saying I don't have proof that there was
a conspiracy by existing and former FBI agents
to discredit the hunter Biden laptop knowingly
in order to help Biden and hurt Trump but there
is a pattern of behavior that is so suspicious
that is so uh bizarre and weirdly coincidental
that it merits Congressional investigation
and that is of course or maybe not of course
but that is what is occurring now in Congress
is that they are taking a look at this pattern
of behavior but at a minimum which you
have is the entire intelligence community
a many private actors including some funded
by the federal government most Democrats and
others whipping up an absolute hysteria around
Russian influence operations they call them they
used to call them psychological operations or
misinformation campaigns and there was never
any very good evidence that much was occurring
after 2016. and even in terms of 2016 it wasn't
uh that there was a lot of Russian misinformation
that reached the American people the main event
was its role in uh hacking the DNC and John
podesta's emails and generating media attention
so there was at best grotesque threat
inflation of Russian disinformation
and I think some confusion around
what that means along with a kind of
um you know constant escalation of what was meant
by Russian misinformation you know as Martin gurie
who uh is the author of Revolt of the public which
I think is one of the best books ever written on
the internet points out you should want to know
what Russians think like you should want to know
what Iranians think the idea that if Iranians
are making the Iranian government like the people
we may not like are making their views known
in the United States and in in ways that you
could potentially label misinformation you know if
the Iranians are saying you know um all gays and
lesbians should be persecuted um like we don't
agree with that I don't know that you wouldn't
call that exactly misinformation but you had this
constantly expanding definition and this wasn't
just in the research I did but in others that
would then allow FBI and other agencies to play
an absolutely inappropriate role of pressuring
the social media companies to censor content
that they didn't like sensory users who were not
linked to the Russians in any way whatsoever but
were saying similar things or engaged in similar
kind of arguments you hear this kind of creeping
uh you know McCarthyism I would say all the time
where people people say to me they go well you're
saying what you're saying sounds like something
the fossil fuel companies would say well I mean
it's like the kind of classic you know who else
had who like German Shepherds Hitler liked Germans
you know so you would sort of get this widening
view of misinformation as this like Menace this
kind of Boogeyman that I think merits significant
investigation and then the final thing I'll say
for me that came out of it was just that there
has to be transparency on content moderation and
I've told this to Elon as well by the way and and
hopefully he does it he hasn't yet but there have
to be transparency around what the decisions
that are being made and how they're being made
it's absolutely not proprietary it needs to be
a condition of the right that is established
in U.S law for these social media companies
to operate with liability from things like
lawsuits for sharing copywritten information or
slanderous material it's known as section 230 of
the communications decency Act um that that needs
they need to have transparency about how these
decisions are made and I say this to somebody
that has been personally censored by Facebook
for writing accurate information about forest
fires that the the Facebook sensors argued would
be misleading that there was misleading because
it could lead people to believe things that they
didn't want them to believe that's a very slippery
slope and I unrelated to Twitter it was a piece
um of a email from Facebook Executives telling
the White House under pressure from White House
and and showing the White House saying we have
been censoring accurate information about the
covid vaccines because of the concern that people
will draw conclusions from it that we don't like
namely to not get the vaccination so that's
a very dangerous thing when you have people
censoring accurate information because they're
concerned what people might be doing with it it's
also potentially dangerous to censor inaccurate
information in situations where counter speech
we're simply participating in the discourse
and the dialogue of debunking things is much
better I'm not saying you can always do that it
seems like most platforms do not want to allow
for example Kanye West to post the swastika and
have that next to the advertiser content you know
um because the Versace doesn't want to see
its handbag advertised next to a swastika so
I I get that but but we're talking about issues
of major public importance covid climate change
whether the D platformer president whether whether
the president is involved in his son's business
dealings these are things are absolutely in the
public interest and the and the uh the we should
err on the side of more not less information
and when they are making censorship decisions
they just need to be public about it they need to
be transparent about it it needs to be someplace
where people can see what those decisions were
and why they were made Michael were you shocked
by what you found out with the Twitter files
because I remember reading it when it was first
released and I couldn't believe it the the FBI
the CIA now look I'm half South American this is
what you do to my culture of my country I didn't
expect it to happen with the FBI to its own people
yeah for sure I mean like you know the way
that people dismiss the Twitter files is
they said well we always knew there was content
moderation going on first of all nobody had any
idea that this amount of censorship was going
on of legitimate speech that's just a fact it
was simply not reported there was no evidence
anything where it was just suspicions and they
were being dismissed as conspiracy theories by the
mainstream news media and others who wanted to see
more censorship by the social media platforms but
yeah I mean there is something there's multiple
shocks I mean the first one is just to see
how often FBI was asking for content to be
um for users to be investigated the kind of
normalization of FBI and other intelligence
agencies interacting with senior Twitter
Executives I will say in particular there
were some cases where there were Twitter
Executives who I think behaved nobly
um Joel Roth is somebody who was the head of trust
and safety at Twitter and he was demonized kind of
early on in the Twitter files process but there
were many times where he pushed back against the
intelligence agencies however he did ultimately
cave in on two of the big issues I view Joel
Roth as a very interesting kind of company man you
know like he was kind of a real professional but
it shows the limits of what real professionals do
in situations where they're under really intense
pressure and all the way to the point where I
was describing where you see the the Facebook
Executives sort of being like Oh please White
House see how good of a job we've done censoring
content on vaccines so that's very very shocking
I was shocked by how many people at FBI were at
Twitter I mean we're not talking just low-level
people although they were they were there too
but we're talking the former general counsel
to FBI this is like one of the most senior
Executives we're talking the Deputy Chief of Staff
that's arguably the third most important person
I mean both of them are arguably the third most
important people at FBI when you really understand
how political the director is and how and and the
kind of the lack of clarity we have about whether
things are being compartmentalized or not it is
shocking to give you one example I mean just to
come back to the laptop there's this problem in
intelligence agencies where we know after during
9 11 on the run up to 9 11 that there were people
in intelligence agencies who knew that an attack
on the Twin Towers was being planned but they were
so compartment analyzed or stove piped that that
information didn't get to the right people so this
huge effort after 9 11 to go and not and to go
and break down those stove pipes that's why they
part of the reason they created the Department of
Homeland Security well here you have a situation
where FBI is in the possession of the hunter
Biden laptop on the one hand and there are other
FBI agents who are telling Facebook and Twitter
that there could be a leak a Russian Hack and leak
operation of information relating to Hunter Biden
that is extremely suspicious now response the
mainstream response would be well that's okay
because those those that's compartmentalized
the people who were warning of the Russian
disinformation probably had no idea or had no
idea that the that they had the hunter Biden
laptop but then that raises other concerns
like like if you have the hunter Biden laptop
and you've got people going around they're
saying oh we have Russian in disinfo on on
Hunter Biden wouldn't you want to know that other
people in the agency had the hunter Biden laptop
that's an important question that would need to be
asked nobody's asked it no one's investigated it
so I found that really shocking um you know I
mean there's other stuff that I think other people
found shocking like the level of just Conformity
and unanimity around issues like gender ideology
around the around the kind of conflating of
conservative views with um hate speech um the
kind of conflating of questioning whether the
vaccine is is appropriate for everybody with
vaccine misinformation or denial that surprised
me less because I I live in the San Francisco Bay
Area [Laughter] you know I mean it is like I think
Matt's Ivey posted I think I reposted something
like it was like 90 98 or 99 of Twitter staff
political donations are to Democrats so I mean
the culture is just monolithically hegemonically
woke so that surprised me less but definitely the
engagement of the intelligence agencies I found
rather shocking and disturbing hey KK Do You
Believe In Spring cleaning yes but only when my
wife does it in Russian men who clean executed for
not being real men which is correct well for those
men who are living in the 21st century manscape
has an incredible offer for you manscaped are the
global leaders immense below the waist grooming
and have forever changed the grooming game with
their amazing performance package 4.0 inside
this care bundle you'll find their lawnmower 4.0
trimmer weed whacker ear and nose hair trimmer
crop preserver ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag to hold
your goodies this Elite trimmer is designed to
trim hair on loose skin although your huevos might
look like a couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their proprietary
skin safe technology complete your grooming game
this spring with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit and we'll
have you smelling like royalty the good kind not
prince Andrew get 20 off and free shipping with
the code trigger 20. at manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping with the code trigger 20 at
manscape.com it's time to throw out all your old
hygiene habits and upgrade your life Michael
one of the things that uh I find very very
concerning indeed you've talked a little bit about
it but it's it's the collusion between government
intelligence agencies and big tech companies to
the point where it's kind of hard to know where
one ends another begins because there will be a
revolving door between them and uh you know I I
didn't realize America was a country in which
the White House told you know journalists what
they're allowed to say in the public space
which is effectively what happened right
yeah absolutely um yes so this is there's a lot
to unpack actually in that so we have uh Supreme
Court rulings that are basically there to prevent
the and there's a lot of them over hundreds of
years right so it's it's not um I'm not going
to say the final word on it but generally you
don't we don't allow the federal government to
uh exercise undue pressure on on people to to
censor their speech so then the question is kind
of what is that because of course uh the people
that work at the government the president the the
press secretary the heads of different agencies
they have speech rights too and so they can go
out and they can say Facebook shouldn't publish
this you know so you kind of go are you free to
say that you know um you kind of go well I guess
so I'm in the sense that they can kind of say
they say the New York Times you know shouldn't
say that or the Washington you just sort of that's
what politicians do and we have we actually give
politicians and elected officials quite a bit of
freedom of speech for themselves you know you so
it's also so I guess it's more of a kind of you
know the definition of pornography as you know
when you see it when you see the White House
doing I'll give you this this really specific
kind of series of events you see the White House
and members of Congress threatening to take away
from Facebook and Twitter this section 230
provision which means that they which is
basically what a lot the legal basis for
the existence of social media companies if
um Washington posts make some outrageous
accusation against me and it harms me I can sue
um those laws are obviously much more uh strong in
Britain than the United States but we still have
the same rules if somebody does that on Twitter I
can ask Twitter to take it down but but Twitter is
not responsible for that that's a big difference
between a traditional media organization and a
media platform so when you start getting so
so you can see how how quickly and how easily
you move from The New York Times is wrong when
they said that to Facebook shouldn't you know
or Twitter shouldn't publish that New York Post
piece you're moving from media to platform and
most people just are regular experience of it we
don't experience those as sort of different things
it's kind of like yeah I go read Twitter I read
the New York Times these are all the same thing
you get them sort of threatening to take away that
section 230 because of concerns around so-called
vaccine misinformation and then it's Relentless
and there's other people that were just more
aggressive there's this guy in particular Andy
slavitt who's just a demagogic activist Zealot
frankly demanding that this guy Alex Berenson who
by the way I mostly don't agree with or maybe I
agree with him on like 50 of his writings just
demanding that he'd be deep platform from Twitter
which they did um baronson actually sued and so
we actually have all of his internal information
from Twitter from his lawsuit and we were able to
see how it related to the stuff that we saw but
you see them pressuring that or saying to Facebook
you've got to stop this accurate information about
vaccines from spreading because it could lead to
vaccine hesitancy you kind of go that just like
you know it has to get in front of a court and
there is court cases on it but I just think as
an ordinary you kind of go that crossed the line
you know that sort of population of events it's
not to say it's always going to cross the line
or that there's some easy thing but you kind
of go this intense pressure particularly to censor
accurate information and with the threat of taking
away what is the legal basis of these corporations
strikes me as potential First Amendment violations
right uh and Michael the other thing I wanted
to ask you is in this situation one of the big
concerns for me uh is that we know for a fact that
the all of these social media companies not just
Twitter but Facebook and you know obviously
Instagram which is owned by Facebook and and
others they would meet together and come up
with strategies so it's not an act accident
that Donald Trump was deep platformed from several
things at once right so is it reasonable to assume
that what was happening at Twitter and we now
know what was happening in Twitter because a
guy that wasn't part of the system bought
it is almost certainly what was happening
at Facebook and what was happening at YouTube and
probably continues to happen on on those platforms
oh yeah absolutely and we know that there was
that FBI and and the intelligence agencies
organized a little group of all the social media
companies and they would have regular meetings
particularly in the run-up to elections and just
as a kind of I'm a trained Anthropologist and so
as an anthropologist you kind of go what they're
sort of doing is they're kind of trying to create
a culture and the culture they're trying to
create and is or sort of a tribe you know
and they're trying to and we know how that works
psychologically right so you're starting to kind
of get this inappropriate levels of identification
with the intelligence agencies we're sort of like
all of us good people on the side of protecting
the you know the children you know the public
it's very paternalistic from this dangerous
misinformation from malevolent actors you know
that was kind of the picture that they're sort of
trying to construct deliberately or accidentally
that's sort of coming from these intelligence
agencies it's also coming from these frankly
very suspicious and in many cases is noxious Bad
actors who are private organizations receiving
Federal funding includes the Stanford internet
Observatory an organization called Graphica some
of them did some probably okay work but they were
involved in this thing of like there's something
really fundamentally wrong where it's like you
kind of go I say with journalists too they go
oh I'm an expert on misinformation it's like no
you're 25 years old you know like you don't have
any you can't just go and be like I'm an expert in
all misinformation I mean like it's so weird when
you think about it it's sort of like I'm the truth
teller you know I'm here to and you guys are all
suspicious it's like I worked on like apocalypse
never my book on the environment was literally
20 years of life experience it has 1200 footnotes
you can imagine it's like you might disagree with
it or whatever we can disagree over the evidence
but you go and have some you know uh in like just
someone that is doesn't know the topic at all
they're basically just going they're allowing
basically special interest to then control what is
allowable and it was so I don't even get it's not
like I even get to have a debate with my with my
Star Chamber Of accusers You know I try to appeal
their censorship of me and they said it would go
talk to the sensor I mean the Inquisition had a
better appellate process than that you know so you
you sort of get this kind of creepy organization
of this kind of Star Chamber or Star Chambers and
then like you said yeah there's people revolving
in and out it's both from the government to the
social media companies to these non-profits that
are funded by the government you get a strong
alliance with the Democrats and the Senate who are
really trying to control it I'm not saying there
weren't some bad things done by Republicans even
Trump when he was president um but it was clearly
coming from the woke Progressive National Security
left as strange as that may seem it's it's such a
bizarre thing and also as well Michael the thing
that I find really troubling about the about this
entire story is that it didn't get basically the
response that it deserved and there's a part of
me thinking do you think that this is just going
to go away and we're never going to really find
out the answer and there's going to be a cover-up
well that's a very interesting question so I mean
if you look at how it's developing there's so many
different kind of threads here as well but so
so I mean I think we know like historians you
know I've done a lot of stuff on nuclear as you
guys know like after World War II and whatever
and it's like there's just a lot of information
would come out decades later and years later so
as a historian you look back you do have some
confidence that more and more information will
come out and so we're still in early days right
I mean Elon just we were just there in December
so yeah like two months less than two months
from when we started looking through the files
you have Congressional investigations beginning
and then there's other things that are sort of
there's other things that are not exactly like
investigative work like I was making a big deal
of we're working on a piece that we're going to
publish today about a major four-part Series in
the Columbia journalism review which is like the
most important kind of journalist magazine in the
United States in part because it's at Columbia
University which gives out the Pulitzer Prize
which is our highest journalism award it was a
four-part series just absolutely just trashing
the media's coverage of alleged Trump Russia
collusion sometimes called Russia gate that
piece was I mean for me too it just was sort
of game changing in the ways in which it not
only debunked a lot of that stuff because some of
it had been debunked already but the way it kind
of put it together and exposed how the media
was doing it so Francis I guess an answer to
your question I'm actually pretty confident
that more information is going to come out
um through these investigations and other
investigations I also think that you sort of of
like because there was a thing where we were sort
of just trying to kind of there's a way because
like people were like how did it work and it was
like it was kind of a smash and grab operation at
Twitter you know we'd be like can we need these
files and you get these files and you're going
through them in because people were like were
they filtering the files for you and there was
no way I mean they were giving us these huge
like they just didn't have enough staff barely
to do the searches and they were giving them to
us and they were kind of going through them and
Reporting on them but it's taken me some time and
I've got more to say about it of what I think some
of the implications are and and like and how these
things kind of were connected to each other over
time you know one of the things I discovered in
in the Twitter files was that the Aspen Institute
had organized what they call a tabletop exercise
which is like a workshop that included the heads
of trust and safety at Facebook and Twitter the
top National Security journalists at the New
York Times in the Washington Post to basically
do an exercise about how to how to not cover
um a Russian leak of information relating to
Hunter Biden they did it on a phone call and
in person I believe in August and October and
it was the weirdest I mean it gave me chills it
was the creepiest thing I'd ever seen I was kind
of like boy if that was being really run by FBI
that's election interference and interference
in the operations of a journalist organization
the the journalists themselves are behaving in
really weird Behavior I mean when you imagine
journalists get together to talk about how not
to cover an issue or how to kind of squelch an
issue you know so that by the time the Hunter
buying laptop came out they had all been mentally
programmed to view it as this information I have
still just because of other things I still have
not yet reached out to the people involved in that
tabletop exercise to ask them what the [__] was
going on because they need to be asked for so long
way of answering questions Francis but but I'm
um I don't think that this is over at all I
do think we're still at the very beginning I
think there's a lot of work here for historians
for journalists for media critics and others you
know I I even my own reporting I have to go back
and re-read my Twitter files to remember there's
so many details there's so many things that you
discover later so no I think we're at the very
beginning it's it's I think it's very exciting
too because you know Elon who obviously I don't
agree with on everything is still making those
Twitter files available so more searches are
still possible yeah and Michael I want to move
on to to Davos the WF and the gray reset and all
that but before we do one final question just on
the journalism side of things I I'm not naive as
naive as I was five years ago when we started the
show and yet I still thought this story coming out
would get massive coverage in the mainstream media
around the world and I looked they and I put it on
my Twitter and to the tweets were very popular
because I think a lot of people felt the same
day after day Twitter files after Twitter files I
would look on the BBC the telegraph the times the
guardian the all the big newspapers in the UK
and a lot of the ones in the United States and
they would talk about you know Elon Musk fired
some cleaners who were upset now the you know
here's 10 cool things you didn't know about Elon
Musk and whatever but not one of them covered the
Twitter files at all how is that possible how did
that happen are the three of us insane are we are
we The Crazy Ones are we obsessed about this stuff
that no one cares about is that what's happening
here because either I am insane or something
seriously weird's going on here no I mean you're
I mean not only that but there was some polling
done by Harvard um around the Twitter file so
first of all the shocking thing is how many people
did hear about the Twitter files despite it not
being in the news media on my Twitter thread
which was um not the biggest but one of the
top biggest ones a hundred million people viewed
it and I was like when I was at Christmas with my
family I was like yeah 100 million people read my
Twitter thread and not one of them is in my family
literally like nobody in my like literally like
nobody in my family knew about the Twitter phones
even though I had done it and I had already
sent it out to my email it just literally
so you kind of go who's censoring what I mean my
Progressive friends and family are are censoring
and then the news media are censoring you
know um and you know it was covered in the
Washington Post very dismissively um just sort
of saying that we that there was nothing new here
um you know that we always knew there was content
moderation or Michael Schellenberg was a legend
of conspiracy and there's no evidence of a
conspiracy um you know as opposed to like
you know I'm very clear I'm not saying I
have proof I'm saying there's a pattern of
of events and information that is extremely
suspicious and merits further investigation
um and then of course they say these
investigations are just witch hunts
um so yeah I mean it's it's it's shocking we
should continue to be outraged I think it's
a permanent feature now of the media environment
that that there's this level of fragmentation and
and censorship and you know like I mentioned
this Columbia journalism review article about
Russia gate that came out yesterday media haven't
written about that either I suspect they won't
um and so I think that older journalism which
was attempting to be fair and objective and give
um voice to both sides is really gone
and that to the extent to which people
want diversity in their media diet they just
have to get it from from different Outlets
Davos is a grift and a cult but it's
also a bid for global domination
[Music]